نتابع الوضع الميداني فيما قمه الايجاد
منعقده في جيبوتي وعلى راسي جدوى لاعملها
الازمه السودانيه وما يجري في السودان
نتابع الوضع الميداني من شرق الخرطوم
تحديدا مع مراسل الجزيره اسامه السيده
احمد وكنت قد ذكرت لنا عن سماع ذوي
انفجارات في بعض المناطق هل اتضحت
المناطق المستهدفه بهذه الانفجارات وكيف
هو الوضع في هذه اللحظات
حسن يعني في موازاه الجهود السياسيه
والدبلوماسيه في اديس ابابا تستمر هنا
الحرب ما بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع كنا قد تحدثنا عن انفجارات دبي
انفجارات عنيفه ومتتاليه في بعض المناطق
من ولايه الخرطوم في ام درمان في وسط
اندرمان وشرقها كذلك
تسبب في ارتفاع سحب دخانيه في المنطقه
التي سقطت فيها القذائف المدفعيه كذلك
نشير هنا الى التطور ابرز هو يعني قبل
يعني ساعه قبل قليل اندلعت معارك عنيفه
سقيمت فيها جميع الاسلحه من خفيفه ومتوسطه
وثقيله في منطقه شارع الوادي بام درمان
طبعا هذه المنطقه ايضا لم تكن معهوده
كمسرح ثابت للمواجهات المسلحه ما بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع ما يعني ان
والاكثر اشتعالا على الاطلاق منذ بدايه عن
هذه الحرب في منتصف ابريل الماضي ولكن حتى
الان تستمر في جبهات قتاليه متعد